the Joe Rogan experience it's terrible
it's a bony lump bag oh it's really
terrible as one mm-hmm
I mean I'm not saying you have to be a
bodybuilder no but you have to [ __ ] it's
just it's you should keep your body and
moving away it's just a laziness thing
it's a discipline thing and yeah like
this idea there's some sort of nobility
and humility and not caring about your
body it's silly I won't get one you get
one it doesn't make you dumber if you
workout stop I know that jocks were
[ __ ] and people bullied you I get it
yeah but goddamn it take care of your
[ __ ] meat vehicle just go take care
of it yeah the meat skeleton people oh
you're vain that's why you work out yes
sure that too I like looking good I like
it it's better to me than not looking
good I'm sorry I'm willing to put in the
time but you know what the irony is so
because of the type of because of the
growth growth of MMA chanting cheers
Cheers my brother because the growth of
MMA CrossFit all of these all these new
worlds that have kind of emerged
socially now that are so much bigger
than they were years ago nerds from that
I grew up with a high school and now
we're into working out yeah that's the
irony that's a big thing with jiu-jitsu
that's I'm saying it's like the biggest
like insecure people now they found a
home in something that's discipline it's
good it feels good to move your body it
feels good it feels good to do things
whether it's taking a dance class I'm
not into that but taking karate I know
that yet did I like yoga I like running
like doing jujitsu obviously I like all
kinds of martial arts and I just like
moving my body man I like running up
hills you move your bodies ain't it
going
you'll feel better afterwards I know you
don't want to do it I never I [ __ ]
hardly ever want to do it if maybe
wanted want to actually do it five out
of ten times but I feel s yeah
but I do it I just do it I know what
it's like to not want to do it I get it
shut up I just start talking to myself I
go come on [ __ ] what are you talking
about do it if I was you outside of you
knowing what I know if I could read my
mind I Billy come on [ __ ] you just
being lazy put your [ __ ] shoes on get
a sweat go and then you're gonna feel
pumped come on man you've done this a
million times and
then invariably I'll be in the middle of
the workout I'm sweating like [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah and then I get into it it's
like just you got to push past that
creepy resistance that Steven Pressfield
wrote about in the war of art it applies
not just to art not just to writing
replies it applies to cleaning your room
and applies to saying you're sorry to a
friend it applies to taking care of a
debt all those things you just keep
putting off it's this weird thing that
you have well you when you see a problem
you gotta fix it
see the thing you have to do go do it
when you know something's like clean
your [ __ ] room right
that's what Jordan Peterson always says
clean your clean your rooms right in
your room and that's that really is what
he's means get your [ __ ] in order yeah
well dude I think I I think it's also a
personality trait though to to be fair
like I [ __ ] I'm someone that has to
get it done you know what someone goes
you don't see do it all at once I'm the
opposite I'm like yeah you do yeah you
[ __ ] do like my she wants new blinds
at the house what if we just did the
living room for now I was like none of
us do get the whole [ __ ] thing done
what's the difference that's a manly
thing to say to get it [ __ ] gone
what can we just have this window no
this window just this will be my shade
spot the truck up all around would be
simple [ __ ] blinds I want trees
around this house I want to walk around
my trails you could buy an old tree you
know that you could buy like I want to
tree in my yard it's 500 years old
they'll find you one that's dope though
that's cool to be like place it here I
got a [ __ ] I have a hundred fifty plus
old oak tree in my backyard
[Applause]